All right, the news continues pouring in.
Things have simmer down a little bit from
the inside insurrectionist riotous coup
attempt by Trump supporters that took place
on Wednesday. But a lot of crazy is really going
on. I told you yesterday that Facebook and Twitter
had temporarily suspended Donald Trump for posting
election dissing for disinformation and incitement
to violence. We have now heard from Mark
Zuckerberg. Facebook will be blocking Donald Trump
on all its platforms, which includes Instagram,
at least until the end of his presidency. Mark
Zuckerberg made a post about this yesterday.
And, you know, I don't really care about
Zuckerberg in the term in terms of evaluating his
morality and his personal politics. I know that
there's reason to be very upset as to how Facebook
has sort of looked the other way with a lot of the
completely ridiculous ways that the Trump campaign
and the right have used Facebook to spread
disinformation and so on. This statement from Mark
Zuckerberg is what it is. And Zuckerberg wrote,
The shocking events over the last 24 hours clearly
demonstrate that President Donald Trump intends to
use his remaining time in office to undermine
the peaceful and lawful transition of power
to his elected successor, Joe Biden. And he goes
on to say, We believe the risks of allowing the
president to continue to use our service
during this period are simply too great.
Therefore, we are extending the block we have
placed on his Facebook and Instagram accounts
indefinitely and for at least the next two
weeks until the peaceful transition of power
is complete. So a an indefinite ban on Facebook
and Instagram for Donald Trump. And it's all just,
you know, the struggle with these incidents is
that on the one hand, all of this stuff should
have happened long ago. Trump's cabinet should
have considered the 25th Amendment long ago.
Trump's cabinet should have resigned long ago.
Republicans should have abandoned Trump long ago.
Pence should have distanced from Trump long
ago on Twitter and Facebook, all this stuff.
But at this late stage, it's sort of like, come
on, guys, it almost feels like a virtue signal
in some sense to me in order to really try to
rehabilitate one's image. And one could be a
person or a company when it's too little, too
late, when Trump is now already weakened and
humiliated with just, you know, 12 days left until
the inauguration. So while these are obviously the
correct decisions, it's hard to really feel
like, wow, it's so great. Everybody's now
figuring it out. We figured it out before Trump
was even inaugurated and some of us were called
alarmists. And, of course, every one of our worst
fears came true. So we'll continue to follow this.
I believe it's quite plausible Trump will
be permanently banned from Twitter as well
after he leaves office. But it is it's
really anyone's guess at this point. And
one of the things I think it's important
to remember, I mentioned this yesterday,
let's not allow the retroactive rehabilitation of
the image of a lot of these people that were along
for the ride, ninety nine point nine percent
of Trump's term and now are bailing absolutely
massive conflict within Trump's cabinet on
Wednesday as the violent insurrection was
breaching the capital. Donald Trump denounced
Mike Pence and said Pence didn't do it.
Pence didn't do it. He didn't steal the election
for me. And that tweet was ultimately taken down
by Twitter. And it was one of the tweets that
led to Donald Trump's suspension on Twitter.